if you are going to threaten people you  need to be totally willing to make good  on that threat if you are not then you  are putting yourself in Greater danger  it's a lot of the way we talk in this  country we behave as though we will face  no consequences for our actions we do  this even on the right when we talk  about Civil War well we're in the midst  of a Civil War in this country it's a  cold Civil War it's a cultural Civil War  are you really ready to be in a civil  war whenever people ask me do you think  Michael the conservative States should  secede do you think we should get a  little more aggressive in our civil war  that we're in this country I think look  maybe you're eager for war I'm not I  don't support conservative states  seceding because no part of a country  has ever seceded from another part of  the country in a totally peaceful way